- [Instructor] In this video,
we're gonna do an example
that gives us a little bit of practice
to think about what does it
mean to divide by a fraction?
So if we wanna figure out
what eight divided by 7/5 is,
but we're gonna break
it down into two steps.
First of all, we're gonna
use these visuals here
to think about how many
groups of 7/5 are in one.
Or another way of thinking about it
is how these 7/5 are in a whole?
So pause this video, and just
think about this first part.
All right, so let's look at 7/5.
7/5 is everything from
here, all the way to there.
And then one is this.
So how many 7/5 are in one?
Well, you can see that one,
which is the same thing
as 5/5, is less than 7/5.
So it's actually going
to be a fraction of a 7/5
that is one, or that is in one.
And you can see what that fraction is.
One is what fraction of 7/5.
Well, if you look at the fifths,
7/5 is of course seven of
them, and a whole is 5/5,
so five of the 7/5 make a whole.
So the answer right over here is 5/7.
5/7 of a 7/5 is equal to one.
You can also see this right over here.
If you take each of these to be a fifth,
each of these to be a fifth,
then this whole bar is equal to 7/5.
And the blue part is equal to one.
So how many 7/5 are in the blue part?
Well, we can see it's
5/7 of the whole bar.
Once again, 5/7 of the whole bar.
So we can also think about this
as one divided by 7/5.
This is another way of saying
how many 7/5 are in one,
or how many groups of 7/5 are in one?
And this is equal to 5/7,
which we've learned in other videos
is the reciprocal of 7/5.
The numerator and the
denominator is swapped.
So now what is eight
divided by 7/5 going to be?
Well, if one divided by 7/5 is 5/7,
or if you have 5/7 of a 7/5,
of a 7/5 in one,
I know the oral language
gets a little bit confusing.
Well, you're going to have
eight times that many in eight.
So this is going to be the same thing
as eight times, we could do it this way,
eight times one, divided by 7/5.
Or you could just view this as eight times
the reciprocal of 7/5,
which is five over seven.
And we've learned how
to multiply this before.
Eight times 5/7 is going to be equal
to 40/7, and we're done.
You could obviously also
write that as a mixed number
if you like, this would be
the same thing as 5 5/7.
So the big picture is when we think about
how many of a fraction are in one,
that's the same thing as saying,
what's one divided by that fraction?
As you see visually here,
you essentially get the
reciprocal of that fraction.
And so if you take any
other number other than one
divided by that fraction,
you're essentially just gonna multiply it
by that reciprocal, because
it's that number times one.
So when you divide by that fraction,
it's that number times the reciprocal.